We Begin tonight in Saint where at least  one person is missing after a violent  explosion at a propane facility  approximately 15 firefighter 50-50  firefighter coming to sing to proceed to  the extinguish of the fire  the explosion happened  and a well-established local  firefighters tried to intervene but had  to back off due to risk of further  explosion and the environmental risk of  gas or oil ending up in a nearby River a  state of emergency has been declared in  the community and neighboring homes and  businesses were evacuated the SQ has  launched an investigation  already our investigators are doing some  verifications about people missing who  were regularly working there where are  they are we able to locate them  elsewhere but we believe that at least  one person is missing it might be a  was probably on the scene when the the  explosion happened  Municipal officials say those evacuated  will gradually be able to return to  their homes this evening